[Music]
hello hello how are you doing hi I like
all real [ __ ] in front of me and all
[ __ ] aside
I've been sick with it my whole life and
I didn't even die yo bro 200,000 raps to
never had to lie i watch passion of the
price twice and I didn't even cry got
the flush of a record deal rimmel rimmel
is in LA
that's his intern Bernard yo we've been
goin hard for like three years
hey Owen I got a show no one is a rapper
Oh tonight this show is gonna get us the
deal mine's about 8:00 it's not
murdering that mic out there that's
what's Khalifa do you think variants
wrong I know this will come as no
surprise to anyone here but Wiz Khalifa
has some incredibly strong weed
[Applause]
real recognize really uh neighboring no
doubt yo is this it is strong
[Music]
so the callin of seizure boy and they
even have a seizure dance your seizure
boy this guy stick for Johnny's done
your rap career it's not over in ninth
grade I told you and if you let me be
your manager I would go ham for you
tonight
the after party to end all after parties
everyone in the game will be there
French Montana
yo this is put your team all you have to
do is spit a fire Burson and we got
ourselves a record deal got a plan to
get us in the kid always comes through
in the clutch the kid rarely comes
through in the clutch
yeah she's got a point the kid basically
never comes through in the clutch yeah I
want to get in here come back with a
whole lot of [ __ ] I don't come back
at all
do you want to come to the after-party
no get a record deal before the sunrise
[Music]
you gotta chew man what's up what's up
what's up
[Music]